- Our first guest, though,
knows a thing or two
about bestselling albums.
He's so incredibly talented.
He's sold over 75 million worldwide
and won five Grammys, no big deal.
(audience cheering)
But now he's got a whiskey.
It's called Fraser & Thompson,
and it's available online and
at select spirit retailers.
So please welcome my Buble!
Mi-- What?
(jazzy music)
(audience cheering)
- Hey there.
- Hi.
- Did you me say "my
Buble" instead of Michael?
- No, but I like it.
- Cool, cool.
- That's nice.
Hi everybody!
(audience continues cheering)
- I love that it at least happened
with you, because you're funny.
(Michael laughs)
So I literally, instead
"--chael," I said "my Buble!"
Instead of Michael Buble.
- That's so cute.
- You're now mine.
Yeah.
- I want to be your Buble.
- I just collected you.
- I want to be your--
- How are you?
- Hi, Kelly Clarkson!
- Hi!
- [Michael] Happy New Year,
how was your New Year?
- Thank you, New Year's
was great, I did a show!
What did you do?
- I hung out with the family.
I was in Miami.
It was amazing.
(audience laughing)
I have four kids.
- Four kids?
- Yeah.
- Do you sleep?
- Do I sleep?
No--
- I've had four kids
in my household at once before.
That's a lot.
- I'm too busy making kids.
- Yeah, yeah.
Congratulations on that.
Okay.
- Thank you.
- Do you ever, do y'all
make resolutions or goals
or anything, do y'all do that?
- Yeah, of course, yeah.
- Okay, what are some of yours?
- Mine was go to the gym every single day.
- Oh.
- Eat no more,
no more carbs, no more sugars.
- Okay.
So how long did it last?
- I failed everything.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- Lasted until the second.
- Yeah, I don't even set
that goal anymore, man.
I don't even, I'm like, why lie to myself?
- Yeah.
I could die tomorrow.
I'm gonna die with sugar on my tongue.